et l'ordre du jour appelle la question
orale de Messi Michel Magra c'est
Monsieur le Ministre de l'Outre-Mer
et monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègue le décret du 15
avril 2013 qui ramène de 16 à 6 mois de
traitement et d'ici à l'indemnité de
suggestions géographique des
fonctionnaires et magistrats en poste à
Saint-Barthélemy suscite l'inquiétude du
corps enseignant cette diminution
conséquente aurait pu être lu à l'aune
des contraintes budgétaires que nous
connaissons mais la fixation de la même
indemnité entre 10 et 16 mois de
traitement pour les fonctionnaires en
poste à Saint-Martin soulève une
incompréhension la collectivité de
Saint-Martin est un effet voisine de
seulement 20 km de Saint-Barthélémy et
surtout le coût de la vie est nettement
moins élevé à Saint-Barthélémy les prix
sont au contraire particulièrement élevé
cela tient à de multiples raisons parmi
lesquelles la totale dépendance aux
importations les trois thèses du
territoire qui provoquent une pression à
la hausse sur l'ensemble des prix y
compris sur ceux de l'immobilier
dans ces conditions la diminution de
l'indemnité aura immanquablement pour
effet d'alourdir mécaniquement les frais
d'installation les enseignants qui
seront affectés sur l'île la
modification des conditions matérielles
place de plus les deux collectivités
voisines en concurrence dès lors que la
demande d'affectation est en volontaire
les candidats risquent fort de favoriser
le territoire le plus avantageux du
point de vue matériel le contexte
économique de Saint-Barthélémy est déjà
source d'une pénurie d'enseignants
obligeant pendant longtemps à recourir à
des personnels contractuelles situations
que ces nouvelles règles indemnités ne
feront qu’apster en l'absence
d'amortisseur financier en réalité les
enseignants ne bénéficient pas de
logements de fonction ils sont les seuls
fonctionnés à des tas est réellement
impactés par la baisse d'un indemnité de
simple à Saint-Barthélémy car rue égard
au niveau des prix localement le
logement représente un poste de dépenses
fixe important
si les autres catégories de fonctionner
à des tas ne sont pas concernés c'est
parce qu'elles sont soit logées par
l'État soit par la collectivité
elle-même par convention avec l'état
antérieur à l'entrée en vigueur du
statut de collectivité autonome en outre
le décret précité fixe le même régime
indemnitaire pour
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon qui en tant
qu'homme avec Saint-Barthélemy il a
faiblesse de la population
ceci laisse donc à penser que c'est le
critère démographique qui a présidé à la
révision du dispositif or à
Saint-Barthélémy du fait justement de
son poids démographique faible le nombre
de fonctionnaires qui pourraient être
concernés restent limité dès lors
l'impact budgétaire d'un alignement
d'indemnité sur celle de Saint-Martin
sera lui aussi limité aujourd'hui sur 45
enseignants présents sur l'île seul 12
d'entre eux ont été bénéficiaires de
l'indemnité dans ces modalités
antérieures enfin cette réforme risque
d'avoir pour haute effet de dissuader
certaines catégories d'enseignants de
postuler pour Saint-Barthélemy ce qui à
terme ne pourra que se répercuter sur la
diversité de l'encadrement pédagogique
pourtant nécessaire sur un territoire
aussi exigu je vous saurais donc
reconnaissant monsieur le ministre de
m'indiquer si un réexamen intégrant
davantage la réalité de la Ferté de la
vie peut être envisagée je vous remercie
un collègue la parole était monsieur
Victorin Lurel ministre des Outre-mer
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Sénateur
vous m'interrogiez sur l'instauration
d'une indemnité de suggestions
géographique
fixé pour la collectivité de
Saint-Barthélemy à 6 mois de traitement
indiciaire du fonctionnaire pour une
durée minimale de 4 années de service
vous ferez une réponse qui est un peu
longue on a deux minutes
et puis une conclusion que l'on verra
comment évaluer la chose et comment
peut-être se revoir si tentait que
l'attractivité pouvait être mise en
cause cette indemnité également
applicable Guyane à Saint-Martin à
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon a succédé le
premier octobre 2013 à l'indemnité
particulière de suggestions
d'installation restauration de
l'indemnité de suggestions géographique
et le fruit d'une longue concertation
entre les différents ministères
employeurs organisés par ma collègue
madame legranchu ministre de la réforme
de l'État de la décentralisation de la
fonction publique il convient de
rappeler que le dispositif précédent le
Lipsy n'avait été créé en 2001 à titre
transitoire pour répondre immédiatement
aux problèmes d'attractivité de ces
quatre collectivités l'objectif était
d'ajuster à partir de critères objectifs
une nouvelle indemnité aux suggestions
particulières et spécifique des
collectivités concernées ces suggestions
sont principalement liées à la situation
géographique notamment l'éloignement des
communes sur certains territoires comme
celui de la Guyane par rapport au centre
administratif mais aussi aux difficultés
inhérentes à certains postes la réforme
menée à bien cette année là pourtant
écarté aucune collectivité précédemment
bénéficiaire de l'indemnité particulière
de suggestions d'installation et la
toute frappe est mis de créer un régime
différencié selon les territoires tenant
compte des difficultés réelles de
recrutement pour chacun d'eux en
dégageant des critères pertinents selon
les affectations et non plus globalement
par collectivité du moins lorsque des
différences de situations de justifier
ainsi des mécanismes de modulation ont
été mis en place en Guyane et à
Saint-Martin des différenciation selon
les affectations ont été clairement
relevées les collectivités ne seraient
donc être mises en concurrence puisque
la réforme répond à des difficultés
spécifiques à chacune d'entre elles dans
cet esprit le critère démographique n'a
pas été prise en compte ni l'impact
financier par collectivité
ainsi la Guyane bénéficie d'un régime
très souple compte tenu de l'importance
des effectifs concernés de la superficie
du territoire et de la diversité des
situations selon les affectations de
même au cours de la concertation
interministérielle de réelles
difficultés de recrutement ont été
relevés dans la collectivité de
Saint-Martin et c'est là que je vous
donnerai une conclusion qui pourra aller
peut-être dans l'autre sens c'est
pourquoi un système de modulation a été
mis en place dans cette collectivité à
l'instar de la Guyane selon des
modalités toutefois moins avantageuses
en revanche à Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon
comme à Saint-Barthélemy le problème de
l'attractivité n'a pas été mise en
évidence par les différents départements
ministériels
toutefois malgré un contexte budgétaire
contraint il a été décidé de maintenir
en régime indemnitaire vous l'avez dit
de six mois dans ces deux collectivités
afin de ne pas créer de situations de
rupture avec le dispositif précédent
susceptible de constituer à terme un
frein à la mobilité dans ces conditions
et même régime forfaitaire de 6 mois de
traitement a été fixé à
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon et à
Saint-Barthélemy l'instauration de
l'indemnité de suggestions géographique
à Saint-Barthélemy prend ainsi un compte
les difficultés propres à cette
collectivité qui sont liées à la Ferté
de la vie
le dispositif mis en place tend donc à
répondre aux problématiques que vous
soulevez la ministre de la réforme de
l'État de la décentralisation et de la
fonction publique et moi-même veillerons
à évaluer l'impact de cette réforme sur
les prochains exercices en liaison avec
les ministères employeurs et si un
problème de d'attractivité se pose
notamment vous dites il y a un caractère
dissuasif je suis prêt à vous recevoir à
en faire l'évaluation et si je veux dire
à aviser
et monsieur le ministre monsieur
je suis le ministre je vous remercie
donc pour le la qualité de votre réponse
et pour son contenu je souscris
parfaitement bien entendu à la volonté
globale de réformes de cet indemnité par
le gouvernement bon vous m'accorderez de
penser que je crains que
l'incompréhension persiste encore un
petit moment chez les personnes
concernées toutefois ce qui me plaît
dans votre réponse c'est cet engagement
du gouvernement à évaluer à suivre à
évaluer et
éventuellement donc réagir en
conséquence sur ce point là et avec
votre accord je veillerai de mon côté à
être le porte-parole de celles et ceux
qui sont concernés et je n'hésiterai pas
à vous solliciter ou à solliciter le
gouvernement en tout cas pour
qu'ensemble nous puissions faire en
sorte que l'enseignement en particulier
l'enseignement destiné aux enfants de
Saint-Barthélémy ne soit pas pénalisé
voilà je vous remercie